[Musique]
onze listes se présentent finalement en
ile-de-france pour les élections
régionales et pour ce nouvel entretien
politique je reçois aujourd'hui pour tv
78 radio sensations la tête de liste
dans les yvelines de la france insoumise
et du parti communiste en élite du tube
bonjour bonjour ancien maire de la
verrière vous êtes au côté de clémentine
autain pour ce scrutin vos deux
formations politiques se sont entendus
mais il y a trois autres listes de
gauche dans notre région celle du ps
d'europe écologie de lutte ouvrière est
ce que la réconciliation est
envisageable dans l'optique d'un second
tour
oui clémentine autain
l'aladi très fortement ce dernier jour
nous sommes très favorables à un
rassemblement de toute la gauche au
deuxième tour c'est la possibilité de
gagner la région
mais comment se passe aujourd'hui
longtemps ce ne serait ce qu'avec vos
partenaires de la france insoumise vous
qui êtes au parti communiste
il ya une manifestation policiers cette
semaine le député de la france insoumise
alexis corbière qui est aussi le porte
parole de jean luc mélenchon n'a pas
forcément été très tendre avec la gauche
l'ensemble de la gauche le ps le pc
également et qui court selon lui après
l'extrême droite il a jugé que la
proposition aussi d'augmenter lé peine 2
de police les peines de prison pardon
pour les meurtriers de policiers et qui
est une proposition de fabien roussel le
responsable communiste français c'était
une piste pas sérieuse donc on sent bien
que l'entente n'est pas forcément très
cordiale alors je crois qu'il faut
rester dans nos domaines il peut y avoir
mais même il peut y avoir des
différences et de taille entre les
parties mais je vous dirais même que
dans les parties des différences
également d'analyser et de position mais
pour l'instant sur les régionales
puisque nous sommes dit sur l'ale la
question des régionales
l'entente se fait bonne se fait tout à
fait normalement on travaille en bonne
entente avec la france insoumise et des
autres partis qui sont dans la liste
parti animalistes et parti de gauche
sociale il ya pas deux il n'ya pas de
nuage je dirais et sur les yvelines
c'est partir que les errements vrai tout
se passe tout se passe au mieux
on travaille ensemble on travaille
ensemble mais le message qui est envoyé
aux électeurs aussi reste celui un petit
peu quelquefois détention alors comment
expliquer aux électeurs et puis comment
les amener aussi à voter pour votre
liste parce que même si vous nous dites
que vous pourriez vous entendre pour
l'optique d'un second tour il va tout de
même falloir passer ce premier tour
donc quel message vous adresser aux
électeurs de gauche
gilles est très clair nous avons un
projet à mettre en place
si nous gagnons c'est un projet social
un projet de qui veut qu'il veut lutter
contre les inégalités sociales de cette
région je vous rappelle que c'est la
région la plus riche de france est la
région la plus la plus puissante au
niveau économique d'europe donc qu'il ya
des enjeux énormes et sur ceux sur ce
terrain nous avons des propositions de
projets de lutte contre les inégalités
sociales de lutte contre les inégalités
territoriales qui sont extrêmement
importantes
là dessus le sujet
et claire et les propositions qu'on fait
sont très claires on se bat là dessus
dans toutes les dans tous les
départements de la région
d'île-de-france de l'âme de la même
façon et le message que l'on envoie
on ne peut plus clair par rapport à
celui la liste de clémentine autain
votre liste figure derrière celle de
julien bayou encore d'audrey pulvar ça
dépend des sondages on est très très
proches les uns des autres
nous menons une campagne très dynamique
très active qui peut nous laisser penser
de tout de façon très raisonnable qu'on
peut être la première liste de gauche au
premier tour
le nom de votre liste pouvoir vivre en
ile-de-france très clairement pour vous
pour votre liste on ne peut pas vivre
aujourd'hui en ile de france quel que
soit le département la situation est
compliquée il ya trop d'inégalités alors
on ne peut pas mais on y vit un de toute
façon quoi qu'il en soit on est on y est
on y vit on y travaille mais je pense
qu'il y a
de grandes améliorations à apporter pour
bien vivre c'est là la différence
je crois que entre départements il y à
des inégalités énormes qu'il faut
essayer de s'améliorer en tout cas voire
de pratiquer à terme donc l'idée c'est
que les gens qui vivent en ile de france
puisse bien y vivre
quand vous avez un bref de logements il
ya des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui cherchent des logements
sociaux qui n'en trouvent pas et
là-dessus valérie pécresse ne nous
aident pas elles à elle a voté un
une décision qui fait que quand on a
plus de 30 % de logements sociaux dans
une ville on ne peut pas en concret d'un
d'une part et de concret d'autre part on
ne sait ça ça bloque un certain nombre
de rénovation urbaine
donc nous l'idée c'est justement de
renforcer ce logement social c'est le
logement social il n'est pas
contrairement à ce que ce que valérie
pécresse véhicule il il est pas que pour
les pauvres gens et les délinquants
logement social c'est fait pour tout le
monde
70 % de la population est éligible au
logement social et nos torts et le
département la région pardon pratiquer
des prix des prix de logements ou dans
le privé qui sont absolument
insupportables donc bien vivre pouvoir
bien vivre en ile de france et on y vit
on y travaille mais il ya largement de
quoi faire pour y vivre beaucoup mieux
le programme de clémentine autain a été
présenté dans son livre publié le 6 mai
dernier aux éditions du seuil
elle évoque un choc des solidarités avec
des mesures fortes mais aussi coûteuse
la gratuité des cantines pour les
lycéens 12 à 19 millions d'euros
des transports gratuits étendue de paris
vers toute la région pour les jeunes et
les plus précaires
comment vous financez déjà toutes ces
mesures ça veut dire que je reprends un
petit peu les propositions de votre
candidate déjà on coupe les aides et
économique aux grandes entreprises et on
les réoriente se sert déjà région 5
milliards budget de 5 milliards d'euros
on a de quoi voir venir d'une part
d'autre part c'est pas l'argent comme
dirait l'autre c'est le problème et pas
où est l'argent
le problème il est où va l'argent est là
c'est un problème politique c'est un
problème de 2,2 choix d'engagement ont
choisi de mettre l'argent valérie
pécresse par exemple choisi de mettre de
l'argent dans l'express de charles de
gaulle qui va qui emmène les gens
fortunés l'aéroport de roissy à paris
24 euros + billet nous ont choisi de
rénover le rer b par exemple le problème
c'est un problème de choix où va
l'argent et c'est vrai que bah oui je
crois qu'on peut arrêter de financer des
entreprises qui font des bénéfices et
qui par ailleurs que licencient et que
cet argent là on peut le mettre au
service des débuts des petites et
moyennes entreprises des commerces et
puis des emplois des emplois
que l'on veut créer et beaucoup des
aides accordées aux entreprises pendant
cette période de crise sanitaire de
crise économique si clémentine autain si
votre liste avait été à la tête de la
région vous auriez procéder différemment
la logique est la même que dans le
projet c'est à dire qu'il ya des
entreprises que bien sûr il faut aider
et d'autres qu'il fonde d'aider des
profits aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont pas
besoin d'être aidé donc la logique qui
exactement la même après c'est du cas
par cas souhaitait également la fin des
aides aux villes qui n'ont pas les 25%
de logements sru on sait qu'il est
parfois difficile pour les communes
d'arriver à ce seuil
déjà parce qu'elles n'ont pas toujours
aussi la main il ya aussi la question
des agglomérations qui pilote aussi les
projets de construction est-ce que c'est
pas une mesure trop stricte où là aussi
ce serait du cas par cas
non je crois qu'il ya une vieille à une
telle loi c'est pas on l'a pas inventé
cette loi il ya une loi elle doit être
appliquée est râlant punit les gens qui
fit bons qui sont hors-la-loi bain pour
le logement sa part la nuit cas par cas
même s'il ya des complications une
impossibilité un manque de foncier et
les choses ça et n'aille pas du jour au
lendemain on peut comprendre qu'il
faille un peu de temps pour certaines
villes mais en tout cas c'est un c'est
un objectif que chaque ville doivent
avoir un peu et pourquoi certaines
villes comme neuilly ont le droit de
d'être à 6% ou je ne sais même pas 10
donc et et que les autres sont à 70%
telle la verrière donc non il ya ya
aucune raison que chaque ville ne fasse
pas un effort pour que les du
lotissement social accessible à tout le
monde
on va arriver à la fin de cet entretien
mais les doutes une dernière question
concernant la sécurité quelles sont vos
propositions parce que tout de même dans
le selon les derniers sondages 44 % des
franciliens place la sécurité en tête de
leurs préoccupations
c'est le dernier sondage ipsos qui a été
publiée début mai pour vous la sécurité
ce n'est pas un sujet très peu de 55
donc non ce n'est pas récent mais 44%
c'est beaucoup et c'est parce que j'ai
une aurifères ont bien sûr que non la
sécurité n'est pas il faut la prendre en
compte mais je vous rappelle que c'est
un service enfin le la police et la
justice d'ailleurs sont des services
régaliens de l'état que à mon sens elles
doivent le rester
donc depuis des années des décennies on
met à mal
ces deux services on a retiré je ne sais
combien de dizaines de milliers
d'emplois
deux postes aussi bien dans la police
que dans la justice d'ailleurs donc
remettons les moyens aux services qui
sont là pour ça d'abord la salle la
police de proximité par exemple on a
retiré une un service qui marche
aujourd'hui ça nous coûte la non
compréhension entre entre la police et
les aider et les rats qui nous coûte
très très cher d'intervenir c'est à
l'état de faire son travail c'est ça on
travaille déjà et nous nous on a un oeil
à la région peut tout à fait intervenir
dans tous quitté médiation et dans tout
ce qui est social je pense que une bonne
partie des problèmes que l'on rencontre
sont liées aux difficultés sociales que
l'on rencontre ce qui ne veut pas dire
que je que chacun n'est pas responsable
de ses actes qu'on me comprenne bien
si amélie duthu je vais devoir vous
interromps pas si nous arrivons à la fin
à la fin de cet entretien
on aura l'occasion de revenir sur les
différents programmes des candidats des
candidats sur les différentes émissions
sur le mois prochain avant le premier
tour du scrutin vous merci à vous et
vous êtes tête de liste yvelines pour
pouvoir vivre en ile de france 11 es
liste au total se présente dans notre
région se retrouve bientôt sur tv 78 sur
radio sensations
[Musique]